there are some things human beings
aren't meant to know and it's the sworn
duty of the scp foundation
to discover and contain such information
but sometimes knowledge is discovered
that shakes even the foundation itself
to its very core
one such discovery occurred on april 28
2016.
that night scp-2935 made itself known to
the foundation personnel
to this day the exact nature of scp-2935
is a mystery that even the foundation's
brightest minds can't completely
understand
everything we know about scp-2935 today
comes from three doomed missions to the
anomalous zone's interior
this is the story of those infamous
expeditions
the nightmare began around 5am when scp
foundation
site 81 in bloomingdale indiana
intercepted a distorted radio signal
communications personnel at the site
traced this strange signal back to the
unincorporated area of joppa indiana
near u.s interstate 70. as is foundation
policy a team of field agents were
dispatched to the location
in order to determine what they were
dealing with however rather than finding
anything that could logically produce
such a signal
they instead discovered a long abandoned
cemetery the most recent death on any of
the tombstones was recorded as being
over a hundred years ago
all the way back in 1908 on further
investigation the foundation discovered
an unmapped limestone cave opening
beneath the cemetery and when they sent
a drone into the depths of the cave it
appeared to quickly exit out the other
side of the cave
but something wasn't right the area that
the drone was observing appeared
consistent with the landscape from which
it entered but now
it looked somehow grayer it lacked the
color of life of the place it just come
from
the grass was dead there were no trees
no shrubs no animals or birds in the sky
they weren't looking at our world they
were looking at a strange reflection of
our world on the other side of the cave
in fact it wasn't a cave at all it was a
passageway between two dimensions
it was scp-2935 just then they were able
to unscramble the distorted transmission
they'd been receiving
it went as follows this is an automated
emergency broadcast from the scp
foundation
and your national government one or more
of our sites is experiencing a
communication breakdown
likely due to a containment breach of
unknown magnitude all citizens are
ordered to stay in their homes as
containment teams work to secure the
breach
this message will broadcast from april
20th 2016
until at that point the message would
cut and repeat
as it had for eight straight days the
message source
site 81 but not this site-81 the scp
foundation was receiving an emergency
distress signal from themselves in
another dimension
a bizarre event that even the foundation
had never experienced before
field agents were terrified by the
implications of what they just heard and
contacted site 81 command to request
additional units
the foundation wished to fully
understand this anomaly as quickly as
possible
due to the potential threat it could
pose toward the foundation so they
dispatched mobile task force
epsilon 13 codenamed manifest destiny
to perform the first of three manned
missions into the heart of the anomalous
zone
the first exploratory mission into
scp-2935 was codenamed gauntlet
and consisted of a four-man team fitted
with full hazmat suits
and direct video and audio links to
mission command the team was led by a
field operative known
only as agent juno his subordinates were
agents kale
devon and underwood their directive was
to gather samples and survey the area
position directly around the insertion
point
meaning the other cave mouth of scp-2935
the mission only lasted about an hour
but what they saw in there would
stay with these men for the rest of
their lives after a 15-minute trek
through the cave manifest destiny
arrived in the mirror dimension where
they were struck by the eerie silence of
a place that seemed identical
and yet so different from their home
dimension the first observation they
made was the total absence of all living
vegetation trees grass weeds
everything it was all dead on orders
from their superiors back in the
original dimension
that we'll refer to from here on as
dimension prime manifest destiny headed
deeper into the mirror dimension of
scp-2935
they traveled two kilometers without
detecting a single sign of plant or
animal life
not even insects eventually they came
upon a farmhouse with two cars parked
outside
with authorization from command manifest
destiny breached the house and headed
inside
agent kale confirmed that there was
still power flowing to the building
as the lighting appeared to work just
fine but they came upon a horrifying
discovery in the house's dining room
three adult corpses two female one male
or seated at the table
a fourth corpse that of a male child was
sprawled out on the ground nearby
as if the death of what looked to be an
entire family wasn't awful enough
the manifest destiny team noticed a
number of other alarming details there
were no signs of decomposition
on the bodies nor did there appear to be
any obvious cause of death
the family's last meal was still on the
table chicken mashed potatoes and green
beans
while the food looked cold and stale
there was no evidence of rot or spoiling
the team found an open newspaper dated
april 19 2016
illustrating that the family may have
died a full eight days before the
discovery
in dimension prime decay would already
be very well underway by that point
yet here there wasn't even a smell
instead everything was just covered in a
thin layer of dust command requested
that manifest destiny collect samples of
the food
as well as hair skin and fluids from the
corpses for further study
small electronics like smartphones were
also taken from the bodies
agent devon turned on the television in
the living room and found that while
most stations were now running test
signals the shopping channel was still
live
well the feed was live at least both
hosts sat in front of the cameras dead
but perfectly preserved the date on the
screen read april 28
2016 suggesting that the times of
dimension prime and mirror dimension
were exactly the same
in fact everything seemed the same the
only difference between the two
dimensions being that some kind of
mysterious apocalyptic event had
occurred in the last eight days
in scp-2935's mirror dimension but
exactly what had happened or how
remained a mystery
when manifest destiny exited the
farmhouse they once again remarked on
the lack of all signs of life around
them
at this point the team returned to the
insertion point of scp-2935
but were instructed to remain in the
mirror dimension while additional units
joined them inside
manifest destiny swelled to 16 members
with the notable addition of agent roy
as the new commanding field officer
the team split into two groups of eight
and agent roy and his men
infiltrated the mirror dimension site-81
while agent juno's detachment attempted
to access the base's off-site deep
storage servers
this second expedition was codenamed
overland and led the foundation's field
agents even deeper into the terrifying
mystery of scp scp-2935
accessing the site was easy for roy's
detachment it seemed there were
relatively few cars on the road at the
time of the mysterious extinction event
in the distance fire still smoldered in
the wreckage of planes that looked to
have just
dropped out of the sky agent roy and his
team like all scp foundation personnel
were fitted with vitals trackers and
they assumed that the distress signal
that started this whole thing
could have been triggered by the deaths
of every member of the foundation at
once
in the mirror universe once inside
site81 they realized that the assumption
was probably right
going door to door in the administrative
wing they found the perfectly preserved
corpses of everyone they knew to be
stationed there in dimension prime
people who were without a doubt still
alive in their universe
samples from the corpses that the
foundation would later study even
confirmed the reason that the bodies
were perfectly preserved
the corpses had experienced complete and
sudden death on a cellular level
and even the bacteria that would
typically take part in the decomposition
process
had died with it in scp-2935 death was
total and absolute
across all types of life forms as agent
roy's team ventured further into the
bowels of site 81 they made another
unsettling discovery
their own corpses in roughly the same
spots they'd been inside dimension prime
site 81 8 days prior
some of the foundation's top scientists
including the esteemed dr
bright were also found dead inside the
facility in an attempt to see just how
far this unexplained phenomenon
stretched
agent roy's team decided to inspect the
containment cells where they found that
all the mirror universe's
scps including scp-2996 were dead
in his desperation to find some kind of
exception to the extinction event
agent roy revealed a terrifying secret
to the rest of his team
scp-682 the immortal misanthropic lizard
and one of the deadliest creatures known
to the scp foundation
was contained at this very facility
right below them
could it have something to do with what
was going on here they descended into
the containment facility to discover an
even more unsettling truth
scp-682 the unkillable anomaly
floated dead in its tank death truly
made no exceptions within scp-2935
agent roy's team left the site and
rendezvoused with agent juno's team to
send their research back to dimension
prime using automated drones
both teams remained in the mirror
dimension for another manned operation
codenamed 19.
they had no idea it would be their final
mission as they descended deeper into
the facility passing more dead scps
they discovered one final clue based on
the activity of the foundation servers
the event occurred
at roughly 3 am while underground in
scp-2935
site 81 the team accidentally activated
the base's on-site nuclear weapon
a fail-safe meant to be detonated in the
case of an emergency containment breach
due to the base's fail-safe protocols
every member of the manifest destiny
team was locked
and sealed inside site-81 they along
with everything else were incinerated in
the nuclear blast
once again the mirror universe inside of
scp-2935 was lifeless
but that isn't where it ends when the
automated drones returned out of the
scp-2935k
to the field operations in dimension
prime they were in for their own
horrifying discovery
none of the footage or information
gathered from scp-2935
illuminated how or why the extinction
event occurred
everyone and everything simply dropped
dead at the exact same moment
nobody was aware nobody was prepared
death came suddenly and silently and
none were spared
all the foundation on dimension prime
were left with was a message from one of
the agents from manifest destiny
agent keller his final message was i
don't have any answers i don't think
there are any i'll do this one thing and
hope that fixes it
seal it shut you've got to lock it in
here with us i'm sorry
the foundation were at first confused by
this until they discovered a final
encrypted audio log
buried in the files recovered from the
mirror universe's site 81
it was a message from keller himself but
not the keller from universe prime
in this message keller described the
foundation in the mirror universe
receiving the exact same distorted
transmission that they did
a few days earlier from a cave in joppa
when he and the others were dispatched
inside
they discovered the same lifeless
post-extinction event world that was now
so familiar to the foundation command
but there was a key difference this
wasn't the mirror dimension they'd just
been studying but a
third entirely different dimension in
his haunting final words mirror
dimension keller admits that whatever
caused the event in that third dimension
an entity in that mirror dimension
keller believed this was the specter of
death itself
and had followed him back into his world
and history had repeated itself
scp-2935 was the passageway through
which absolute death could pass
from dimension to dimension and our
dimension was the next in line
the deaths of manifest destiny may have
saved our entire universe
as anyone passing back through the cave
had the potential to bring death itself
back with them
the foundation decided in the end to
follow keller's advice
they sealed the entrance to scp-2935
with concrete
and now kept it under constant watch
since what waits behind the barrier is
an entity even they have no power to
stop if it ever got through
after all it had killed them all before
or at least
another version of them what's one more
dimension on the pile
why it may now just seem like a simple
slab of concrete under an abandoned
cemetery
this is why scp-2935 might be the most
dangerous scp of all
you